The way that I got my first client, and
clients that paid me six grand a month,
10 grand a month to do marketing for
them, is the same exact method every
time, and it's not cold outreach, and
it's not meta ads or anything like that.
It's friends, okay? It's It's going to
be the same thing every single time. In
fact, here's a book that I recommend. No
plug, just Networking Magic. It's a
great book, and it'll help you build
relationships with people. It'll help
you find the right connections so that
you can know the right people to talk
to, the right people to work for. You
know, a lot of times I did free work for
people. Like, when I first started doing
marketing online, I built websites, and
I would text friends. I'd be like, "Hey,
your website's ugly. Can I redesign it
for free?" You know, and I would do
stuff like that, and I would build those
relationships, and I'd ask them, "Hey,
did you like that website? Would you
connect me with one other person that
may also need a website?" And you just
build relationships over time. It's
going to be infinitely easier for you to
work on your networking and your
relationships and serving people and
building your portfolio by doing the job
and getting the result for people than
it is messaging people via email saying,
"I can 3x your ROAS in five days. I can
write you insanely good co- They don't
believe you. They don't know you. And
the biggest gap that you're trying to
overcome is a trust gap. It's not a
product gap. It's not a marketing gap.
It's not a whatever It's a trust gap.
You're trying to get them to trust you
because people buy things from people
they trust, okay? So, if they trust you
and you genuinely solve a problem, then
they will buy from you. They will be
your client. That is how to get your
first client, your hundredth client. It
doesn't change. So, stop buying courses,
stop following these gurus online, and
start making friends and serving those
friends.